So, you've made it
to the end of Squid Game,
you've survived
all six games,
you've gasped
through the twists and turns
and cried a small
ocean's worth of tears
watching two friends
play a game of marbles.
We made a pinkie promise
to be each other's gganbu.
If you know, you know.
And now
you're looking for more:
more thrillers
that pitch players
in battles to the death,
more dramas
about desperate struggles,
or maybe just more film
and TV from Korea.
Whatever your wants,
Netflix has you covered.
If Squid Game has you hooked
on sinister games
then Alice in Borderland
will scratch that itch.
In this hit
Japanese thriller,
Tokyo is transformed
into a ghost town
as three heroes are pulled
into a violent game show
where they complete tasks
to earn more time
to explore
and escape the city.
And if time runs out…
Let's just say,
don't let time run out.
Based on the Haro Aso manga,
Alice in Borderland shares
Squid Game's sense of style,
and offers deadly takes
on playground favourites
like Tag or Hide and Seek.
Can gaming-obsessed
slacker Ryohei Arisu
get his friends safely
through the challenges?
Find out only on Netflix.
Brazilian thriller
3% may unfold
on the other side
of the Earth to Squid Game,
but it offers
an equally thrilling take
on life-or-death
competition.
In a bleak future society,
citizens are trapped
in poverty
unless they win a place
in an affluent
island paradise.
When residents
hit 20 years of age,
they take part
in "The Process,"
a series of tests designed
to whittle the group down
to the three percent
who get a ticket
to the chosen land.
It's a complex look
at the inequality
that drives
violent competition
between good people,
while also delivering
tense thrills
as the cast tackle
the challenges.
Over 33 episodes,
a fitting number,
3% will get under your skin
and stay there.
Like Squid Game, Sweet Home
hails from South Korea,
but this gruesome horror has
a slightly different energy.
Fragile teen Cha Hyun Soo
moves into a dilapidated
apartment block
to escape a family tragedy
and is met
by unsympathetic neighbours.
Don't die here.
You'll just cause trouble
for a lot of people here.
Won't be bothering her
for a cup of sugar.
But grumpy residents are
the least of his worries.
The security guard's
in a trance,
there are bloody trails
in the corridors
and nosebleeds breaking out
across the building.
Oh, and an army of demons
banging on the front door.
Watching its cast
come together
to fight the apocalypse
will warm your heart,
when the monsters aren't
trying to eat it, of course.
Where Squid Game
has a pig full of money,
Okja is about a pig
worth a lot of money.
Meet Okja,
a genetically-modified
super-hog
bred by Tilda Swinton
as part of her plan
to bring home the bacon
in more ways than one.
Raised by a girl
in South Korea,
Okja grows big enough
to draw the attention
of her corporate creators.
Enter Jake Gyllenhaal,
in one of his wildest
performances to date…
Dr Johnny's…
Magical Animals!
…as he takes the plus-sized
porker to New York,
setting the little girl on a
quest to save her piggy pal.
From the mind
of Bong Joon-ho,
the director of Parasite,
the first
foreign-language film
to win Best Picture
at the Oscars,
Okja is a romp
full of laughs, shocks,
and many shots of Gyllenhaal
in terrible shorts.
Are you ready?
Yes, we are, Jake.
Like Squid Game,
Extracurricular
is another show
looking at
the extreme lengths
people will go to
for a paycheque.
Oh Ji-soo is a brainy
but bashful student.
Think straight A grades
and a crush on a girl
with slow-motion hair.
But he lives a double life,
running security service
for illegal female escorts.
Operating as
the mysterious "Uncle,"
he protects the girls
from violent clients
and takes a cut
of their earnings.
But when his crush takes an
interest in his side hustle,
can Ji-soo balance
his high-stakes business
with his student life?
Extracurricular
is like Breaking Bad
for the sex trade,
minus the hazmat suits,
obviously.
You'll be hooked
after just one episode.
Psychokinesis is a superhero
film with a twist.
When a crooked security
guard drinks infected water,
he gains superpowers,
but can he be bothered
to use them for good?
Great power comes
with little responsibility.
Well, until bullying
businessmen come
for his estranged daughter's
fried chicken shop.
Time for some
finger-licking justice.
From the director
of Train to Busan,
Psychokinesis delivers all
the wham-bam action
of a comic book romp,
but with a nod to Korea's
struggling underdogs.
If you enjoyed
Gi-Hun's Squid Game journey
from selfish gambler
to do-gooder,
then Psychokinesis
is another one
to add to your watchlist.
The Uncanny Counter
shares Squid Game's
love of a red tracksuit,
although, here, the outfits
are worn by the good guys,
a team of superpowered
Counters
who protect the Earth
from evil souls
escaping from the afterlife.
When they aren't
thrashing demons,
the Counters
hide their identity
by running
a noodle restaurant.
So, do not forget
to tip your waiter.
Into their world
wanders So Mun,
who becomes the unlikely
host of the soul
of a recently killed
Counter.
Can So Mun win over
his fellow heroes?
Will demonic forces
conquer the Earth?
And how is he going
to get that birthday cake
out of his hair?
Expect answers
to all this and more
in The Uncanny Counter.
Time to Hunt
is an action-packed thriller
starring Squid Game's
Park Hae Soo
as a cold-blooded killer.
Having wowed us as
Choo Sang-Woo in Squid Game,
he plays a very different
kind of bad guy here,
a professional hit man hired
to hunt down three friends
who robbed
from the wrong casino.
Wave goodbye to Squid Game's
sly, white-collar criminal
and say hello
to a human terminator
who could give John Wick
a run for his money.
We knew he was bad news
the moment we saw
his ear collection.
Never a good sign, is it?
The way Time to Hunt
flips from heist thriller
to chase film
makes it a brilliantly
tense way
to spend a couple of hours.
Interested in checking out
more Korean cinema,
then why not try
The Drug King?
Set in the 1970s,
it tells the true story
of Lee Doo-sam,
a drug smuggler
who climbs the ranks
of the criminal underworld.
Think of it
as a Korean Scarface,
only with lovable superstar
Song Kang-ho
instead of shouty Al Pacino.
Song's natural charisma
is put to excellent use
as Doo-sam charms his way
across international
borders.
He even convinces
his very own Walter White
to work in a pig farm.
Good people skills.
Of course, if you've seen
any gangster epic,
you'll know that what goes
up must come down.
As police close in
and Doo-sam gets hooked
on his own product,
can he escape the chaos?
Check out
The Drug King to find out.
If you thought the players
in Squid Game had it bad,
wait until you meet
the unlucky contestants
in The Platform.
In this Netflix
Original movie,
people live
in a towering structure
where food
is transported down
from the top to the bottom.
The catch?
It's one meal to feed
the entire lot of them.
So the more that people eat
on the levels above,
the less there is
for the people below.
And there are
many people below.
To give any more away about
this dystopian sci-fi horror
would spoil one of 2020's
most devious thrillers.
You'll never look
at leftover food
the same way again,
so probably not one
to watch during dinner.
If you like Squid Game,
those are just a few of the
incredible shows and films
available on Netflix
that we'd suggest watching.
We'd love to hear
your recommendations
in the comments.
And make sure
to give this video a like
if you find it helpful,
and click
that notification bell
so we can be
gganbu for life.